In order to be successful,
people often think they have to
constantly be achieving,
constantly going from one thing to the
next,
crossing things off of their to do list.
But as a consequence,
they're not in the present moment and
their productivity would be so much
greater if they stayed present as well
as their performance on their tasks.
What's Morris that their relationships
would improve drastically.
So what research on charisma shows is
that highly charismatic people are
people who are able to be so fully
present with other people.
And that's what leads to that incredible
connection.
And that influence that they have.
A research shows that our mind actually
wanders about 50% of the time.
And research also shows that when our
mind is wandering,
we are never as happy as when our mind
is in the present moment.
So if your mind is in the future
worrying about something that's going to
happen or in the past because you're
regretting something or angry at
somebody,
um,
you're more likely to feel more negative
emotions.
But when you're in the present moment,
even if you're doing a task,
you don't particularly like,
um,
you'll actually feel happier.
But also a,
what we know is that you'll be able to
be more productive when you're in that
state because you're going to naturally
be focused.
One way that you can start to bring your
mind back into the present given its
tendency to wander is um,
through breathing exercises and
relaxation exercises.
So pure relax your body,
your mind will naturally start to settle
down and breathing is a very effective
way to do that and very quickly.
So meditation practices can really help
you observe your mind,
become aware of its tendencies,
for example,
its tendency to wander and um,
help you through that awareness.
Shift your attention back into the
present moment.
Meditation is an exercise in which you
are engaging fully with the present
moment.
So if it's a fantastic way to train your
mind to be more present with what is
going on right now,
we currently are in a time and age where
multitasking has just become the norm.
We're constantly being pinged by our
devices.
We're constantly receiving emails.
And all day long.
It's as if we were being interrupted
from our stream stream of thought.
What's more is that we interrupt
ourselves so we will interrupt what we
are doing to check our phones for
example.
So multitasking,
however,
it's very draining on our system.
Our attention is constantly in demand.
It's as if you were,
you're working on 12 different things at
the same time.
You can't give your all to one of those
things with meditation practices.
You can really train your mind to be
more present and um,
help you to,
you know,
stay on task with what is going on.
Our research shows that people who
meditate can increase their attention
span.
In fact,
in some research studies,
we use a task called the attentional
blink task in which you show people a
number of different images in very fast
sequence and usually we would only pick
up every fourth image.
We don't actually see the others.
That's why we call it the attentional
blink.
Well,
research has shown that after meditation
retreat,
people tend to not show that attentional
blink or to show it less.
It just very interesting.
It means that if we call him our mind,
were somehow able to pick up things
better in our environment,
which also makes sense in terms of how
divided our mind is with regards to
multitasking and so forth.
When our mind is very settled,
then we're able to literally see more
things register more.